I sometimes fantasize about Splinter
he's Asian he's a rat he's a good father
[Music]
bridesmaids is an absolute classic girls
trip you know those films really
inspired this film in the sense of
debauchery Unapologetic in your face and
like you know breaking out of these
boxes that Society has put us in you
know I love Bruce Almighty so much it
makes me weep you know I I do love the
Austin Powers Series yeah true
Millennial yeah don't ask Sabrina
because they're cuspy they're like
Austin what children of course
bridesmaids that's really one that it
felt like it broke the mold it was like
it was at a time where people were like
are women funny and it's like yeah we
are and it really felt like it helped
the cause in terms of us being here on
the backs of movies like that and I
always like to take it way back to
American Pie that was a movie that when
I saw this already comedy it was a thing
where I saw it and then literally 24
hours later I got a bunch of my friends
to also go see it that's what we hope
happens with this movie as well it
really is so much more fun to see a
movie like this in a theater with a
bunch of friends with hundreds of people
at once I literally really love
bridesmaids and I love Pitch Perfect
love girls trip Pitch Perfect has a
special place in my heart because when
it came out I like the movie so much I
literally thought if I taught myself how
to beatbox I could maybe play The
Sibling of the Asian beatboxer in the
first one in sequels and now here I am I
hate myself because the first thing I
thought of was crazy Rich Asians and
that it's a slight gross comedy I mean
American Pie I saw Seth Rogen before as
all the Seth Rogen movies are on my mind
I do enjoy comedies I like switching off
and just having a laugh so that's what
we're doing tonight I love Mel Brooks
movies and I love the Coen Brothers
those are kind of the funniest to me
ever Pineapple Express one of my
favorites super bad Jackie Chan was a
huge influence in the beginning for me
Shanghai Noon Shanghai Knights 80 Days
around the world midnight run is my like
favorite all-time comedy and I'm gonna
stick with that one that's my movie all
of the Fletch movies which don't
necessarily age that well but
timing is great The Hangover bringing up
baby and and the Philadelphia Story I
grew up watching a lot of comedies with
my dad The Breakfast Club Stripes Fletch
Caddyshack overboard with Goldie Hawn
anything with Madeline Khan young
Frankenstein's one of my favorites Mel
Brooks History of the World I miss those
movies
foreign